7h ce matin rendez vous avait été donné
à un rond-point de pisé pas très loin de
vesoul
et puis changement direction celui de la
vaugine à vesoul cette fois un peu plus
loin
[Musique]
décision est prise de faire d'une
opération escargot un ralentissement
avant un barrage filtrant tu tout
s'organise se réorganise en fonction
dans toute la journée il ya des
déviations du peu se met en place mais
la police est avec nous n'allons rien
plus moins conciliante donc c'est vrai
que ben on fait en fonction de aussi
apprendre et totalement mobile et ça ne
dérange pas de changer trois fois quatre
fois poste à par jour s'il faut quoi
rien n'est défini par avance et sait
comment ça c'est ça on se donnait lieu
le matin à telle heure on sait pas quand
est ce qu'on va terminer les
rassemblements sont annoncés sur les
réseaux sociaux le soir pour le
lendemain l'heure le lieu
et puis le bouche à oreille fonctionne
beaucoup également depuis samedi jour de
la première action et dans le rang des
gilet jaune
on commence à s'organiser pour le
quotidien exemple avec l'europe
on s'est organisé à midi pour la
nourriture certains magasins qui sont
clément qui participe avec nous pour le
café il ya tout le monde qui renseigne
on met tous la main à la pâte
il ya les gens qui emmène le bois pour
se chauffer là on le voit pas là mais
certains autres blocages ça se voyait
il y avait une organisation là c'est
vraiment un truc mais tombent chaque
année mais un plus d'argent on a fait
une quête
là ça va rester je pense courant la
semaine prochaine mais c'est faux on
restera là où sera toujours l'argument
sera là encore on
criera toujours au secours parce qu'on
en a ras-le-bol à vesoul les gilet jaune
se sont donnés à nouveau rendez vous
demain pour de nouvelles actions des
gilet jaune qui restent déterminés
[Musique]